hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play the
castle of devastating diseases okay so I
still hear the music in the background
which probably does not bode well for me
BAM I'm just gonna throw things at door
that don't seem to be OpenAL because
I've had problems before where I haven't
okay he's on his way he's on his way
okay all right okay this door is open
ball hello
okay alright okay okay alright okay okay
okay hang on buddy up my man let me take
this burger well with the door go
there's the door
okay nope all right so he's a-comin
he's not coming on down and I need to
get the hell out of here
let's see wait was I didn't see a way to
make that door go down again so I'm just
gonna oh okay I'm almost out of oil
completely so I'm looking for something
I don't know what though there's a whole
bunch of rooms here I kind of hear mr.
moose man back there a bit but I don't
know oh no he got murdered by this broom
it punched him right in the face he's
dead and glowing why is he glowing why
is he glowing is his penis glowing no
that doesn't make any sense at all come
on open up
okay so broken chair key there we go
Prison bar door key what does that mean
prison bar door the prison has a bar
oh that okay well then I knew you were
gonna be something just a single closet
in a room hey it's okay I'm a doctor shh
shh shh it's okay it's okay I'm just
gonna take this key okay can't use the
item that way okay fine
okay all right okay so we're going to
the bar apparently wait no what no no
there we go got to use it on the padlock
there we go okay so now we go to section
three where we're gonna get drunk and
forget all this crap we're just gonna
drink our troubles away
there is no moose man there is no
Slenderman
there's no nothing there's only me and
my booze by the way for all you under-21
booze is very bad for you very very bad
don't drink it's bad don't do it for
everyone over to anyone meet me at the
bar after this ok so what do we have
here I turn that off myself I need to
start because I have this very bad habit
of overusing my lantern oil whenever I
play amnesia so I just need to be very
cautious about my usage of the oil I'd
like to just lather myself up with the
oil I use it very hello what happened to
you Oh
your patients got off the bed wait a
minute the bed moved rather precariously
Gough there oh now it's slow to move let
me just cover up that mess and that'll
be good some tasty green gas is oozing
from the ceiling I'm sure that's healthy
okay anything under there no hey don't
lock me in here you son of a [ __ ] I
know it's dark I'm trying to save oil
shush your face just shush your face
needs to hush Oh we'll get to it in just
a second your beautiful face your
beautiful beautiful face needs to hush
okay no tinderboxes good thing they're
giving me plenty of tender boxes maybe
that's a hint that I need to use them
okay these are all pushing me off okay
an oven what's the point all this there
seems to be quite a few rooms with no
points which is really cool
because it's kind of adds to the
environment of the game hi oh you yeah
meet up there lunch and not yeah me as
in yeah me Matthew did you yeah meters
in the colloquialism for vomit okay so
this is weird
okay what was that was that nothing
without a whole lot of nothing she
locked up your gabbed up pretty good
hi alright then
well if you're gonna be like that I'll
just go this way good nice big spiral
staircase anything under the stairs
anything anything under the stairs
they're gonna tell me look some oil oil
the rubdown might aching muscles with
aha oil don't rub down my aching muscles
with just what I was hoping for y'all
give you guys want to see me lather up
and then twerk you all guys want to see
some more of that no no you had enough
of that never again never again
hello hi little piggies okay nope here
eat this I don't wanna I'm out of oil
again damn it I did it again I did the
thing again I'm doing the thing now it's
blocking me
something's bubbling over there
something strange some frothy mixture
it's bubbling up let me touch it
oh I need a container for liquid glass
Tara what is on the floor oh this chair
are you serious it's ten pound chairs
blocking me 10,000 pound chair a chair
so fat these guys just don't gravitate
or whatever yeah that's it sick burn on
the chair okay there just seems to be it
just seems to be a lot of emptiness
a lot of emptiness you don't see it like
you'd cut some stories like back you do
original amnesia one quit moaning I'll
be with you in a second I'm a doctor
okay I got a chemistry pot back Andy
really back in the original amnesia
there was a lot of you know environment
to make it seem like an actual castle it
in some cast
custom stories it's often forgotten that
you know you need to have rooms and
rooms and rooms to get lost in because
most of the time it's just a straight
line to your objective or being chased
down the hallway it's nice to have some
true environment in there it's just me
giving game commentary why am I giving
game commentary make more dick jokes
markiplier what are you doing anyway
carrying on wow this is a big sum this
is what I'm talking about what is this
so yeah this is what I'm talking about
there's no other purpose of this other
than to look down at this awesome room
here okay cool
alright okay okay all right okay all
right okay
what happened oh I didn't think it was
actually there that was reckless and
stupid oh hi nice ass
what the hell you son of a [ __ ] ty hate
that music that's the amnesia just steam
music and it's like scarier than any
other music in this game alrighty then
Wow let's carry on then I think he is
gone away forever
hopefully oh look some more Gabby goop
that wasn't there before
oh look here's some more it looks like
that guy gabbed up the whole place with
his goop
why is he gotta be goofing all over the
place what is that why is that that's
not normal that red mist of doom that's
not normal are you in the process of
goofing up the walls
please don't goop up my walls alright
then hey wait didn't no no that's just a
candle never mind I thought that was
actually something nevermind I thought
it was a tinderbox nevermind nevermind
ok so still Gavin up the goop why this
door still locked ok that's probably
where it came from but it's still locked
oh yeah it's got a water bar here don't
bother me I ain't gonna bother you so
don't bother me
okay it's quiet I said it was quiet so
stay quiet bloody friend I'm almost out
of oil I'm trying to conserve it I know
it's dark but jeez oh this is the room
damn look at this place
this is awesome I can barely see
anything but this is awesome I think I
think it's awesome man people better not
jump out and say happy birthday to me
whoa I almost fell off of that
okay go around that wait a minute I
can't go through here I would happen if
I jump down in there
I would die that's what would happen see
I came oh hi how you doing doing good
you look good oh hi nice ass
oh hi okay so I can barely see it would
help if I turned off my lantern but I'm
not gonna do that cuz that'd be stupid
that'd just be dumb okay I think I can
get to this door over here now yes all
right
go in nothing in here well here let me
like this don't waste oil can you give
me some more oil please God why do I
need a hammer don't need a hammer I got
acid oh maybe I need to a sit-up a lock
and then hammer it that probably is that
probably hello mr. Eagles please don't
scare me
ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ok so locked it
in good shape so and braum alright I'm
so strong and handsome and amazing
didn't even need to know anything
don't laugh at me
don't laugh at me okay oh yeah can't
hide from me
oil thank you oh I need more oil look
this is not it no no where are you where
are you I don't see you where are you
where the Frick frack are you where are
you my my my my
oh oh it's a blow yeah oh I'm talking
about yeah
suck on that suck on those big sweaty
balls okay more oil thank you very much
all right is something still chasing me
or am I had a reprieve bit later when I
use the calamari no notice that there
was more side effect with that liquid
the castle is very old and it was huge
amount of moisture injuries when
calamine reaches mildew it will expand
slowly first but after a few hours it
will expand with huge speed and the
mildew becomes very slime and deadly
I suggest you avoid the mildew here dr.
Morgan well thanks dick the suggestion
would have been more helpful had I not
okay
alright we're rewarding the mildew
all right J sequence haven't had one of
these in a while excuse me left right
left right
I don't know what they're all right
cool what's an air to chest so much a
chest give me the damn thing I'm in a
heart rain I'm in a bit of a hurry you
bastard just give it to me just give me
I know that's not good I think I done a
bad thing my greed
could I have gotten that any slower you
sons of [ __ ]
oh my god
[Music]
that was dumb why wouldn't the boxes
open correctly stupid sons of guns just
stupid son did your rock there you go no
no no all right since there were only
tinderbox in there I'm not gonna even
gonna bother with that
fine aha here we go I guess I I still
get to keep all the tender box yay good
for me okay can I close it no I cannot
okay keep going
all right anything else you can throw at
me
what the hell what the body work to the
monster just came flying at me section
one I probably could have gone down that
hole there might have been a secret down
there I have no idea though maybe maybe
not
maybe baby maybe baby maybe baby
maybe okay all right oh hello mildew
really next you're gonna tell me this
was all caused by a fungus and this is
just really the last of us oh I'm back
towards the beginning how are you doing
mr. patient did the calamine help excuse
me I just need to exercise your thoracic
liver here but oh no next patient oh
he's still screaming well just okay he's
okay he's okay he's just gonna
recuperate and apparently I touched that
goop and my eyes have all gone funky
so anyway I'm all out of time for this
part so thank you all so much for
watching click the annotation for more
videos that I've done and as always I
will see you in next video
[Music]
Hey
hi
should I run
[Applause]
I hear something what is it what is that